berberina ou alfa lipoico, qual que
seria que ajuda mais na resistência
insulina ou pré-diabetes? Olha só,
pessoal, vou contar uma coisa que vai
mexer com suas certezas hoje. 97% das
pessoas que sofrem por resistência a
insulina estão escolhendo o suplemento
errado. E eu não estou falando isso para
dar uma de médico sabe tudo, não. Estou
falando isso porque depois de 28 anos de
medicina e milhares de pacientes
atendidos, eu vejo essa confusão todo
santo dia no consultório. Você chega na
farmácia, vê uma prateleira cheia de
suplementos, todos eles prometendo
controlar sua glicose e fica com aquela
dúvida cruel. Bermerina ou alfalipoico?
Um vendedor diz uma coisa, seu amigo diz
outra e você sai de lá com o bolso mais
leve e a cabeça mais confusa ainda. Mas
a real é que a maioria das pessoas está
tomando decisão baseada em marketing,
não na ciência que tá por trás da coisa.
E olha que ironia, os dois suplementos
ou compostos são excelentes, mas cada um
tem o seu jeitinho específico de
trabalhar no seu organismo. É como
comparar um Corolla com uma picap. Os
dois te levam do ponto A ao ponto B, mas
cada um tem a sua especialidade, né?
Deixa eu contar sobre a berberina
primeiro. Esse composto amarelinho que
vende plantas como a cops chinenses tem
uma história de mais de 400 anos na
medicina tradicional chinesa. Mas não
pense que é só papo de vovô, não. A
ciência moderna descobriu que a Bebelina
é um verdadeiro multitarget metabólico.
O que quer dizer isso? Simplesmente ela
ataca a resistência insulina por várias
frentes diferentes, vários ângulos ao
mesmo tempo. É como ter um time de
futebol completo, não só um atacante. A
berberina ativa uma proteína chamada
MPK, que é meio que o diretor de
operações do metabolismo. Quando essa
proteína acorda pra vida, ela manda o
fígado parar de produzir glicose em
excesso, aumenta a captação de glicose
pelos músculos e ainda dá uma mexidinha
na microbiota intestinal. E aqui que vem
um dado que vai te impressionar. Estudos
recentes 2024 mostram que a beberina
pode reduzir a glicemia de jejum, o
açúcar de jejum em até 23% em pessoas
com diabetes tipo 2. Para você ter uma
ideia, isso é quase o mesmo efeito da
mente formina, mas sem os efeitos
colaterais chatinhos que todo mundo
conhece. Mas aí você pode estar se
perguntando, Dr. Alan, se é tão boa
assim, por que que não todo mundo toma?
E aí que dá o pulo do gato. A peberina
tem uma absorção mais complicada que
apenas 0,5% do que você engole realmente
vai entrar na corrente sanguínea. Por
isso que muita gente toma e não vê
resultado. Está tomando a dosagem
errada, no horário errado. Agora, do
outro lado do ring, temos o ácido
alfalipoico. Esse é o que eu chamo de
antioxidante metabólico inteligente.
Diferente da bemberberina que é mais
bruta na abordagem, o alfalipoico é mais
sutil, trabalha com sutileza. Ele não só
melhora a sensibilidade insulina, como
também protege suas mitocôndrias,
aquelas usinas de energia das células do
estresse oxidativo. O que diferencia o
falipoca é sua capacidade de regenerar
outros antioxidantes. É como se ele
fosse o técnico de um time revitalizando
todos os outros jogadores. Ele pega a
vitamina C cansada, vitamina E esgotada,
gluta no fim da carreira e devolve elas
pro jogo renovadas. E tem mais. Enquanto
a beberina foca principalmente na
glicemia, o afaliporco tem um talento
especial paraa neuropatia diabética. Se
você já está sentindo aqueles
formigamentos nas mãos ou os pés ou
aquela sensação de que está pisando em
algodão, o alfalipoico, ele pode ser o
seu melhor amigo. Mas aqui eu preciso
ser honesto com você. A abordagem
integrativa que eu uso no consultório me
mostrou uma coisa que pode soar
controversa. A pergunta não deveria ser
berberina ou alfalipo? A pergunta
deveria ser como usar os dois de forma
estratégica? Porque cada um tem o seu
perfil ideal de paciente. Se você tem
uma resistência à insulina mais
estabelecida,
com síndrome metabólica bem instalada,
disbiose intestinal e colesterol nas
alturas, a bemelina pode ser sua carta
na manga. Agora, se a sua resistência
ainda está no comecinho, se você tem
estresse oxidativo elevado ou já está
desenvolvendo algum problema
neurológico, o alfalipôico pode ser mais
certeiro. Eu vou te dar um exemplo
prático no consultório. Semana passada
tem um executivo de 45 anos. sedentário,
barrigão de chope, o homem rá em cima.
Para ele, a beberina 500 mg duas vezes
ao dia, antes do almoço do jantar teve
um bom resultado, 60 dias, glicemia de
jejum normalizada, perdeu 8 kg sem fazer
dieta maluca. No mesmo dia atendi uma
professora de 52 anos, pré-diabética,
mas já com sinais de enduropatia. Para
ela, ela falipo com 300 mg em jejum pela
manhã. Em 3 meses, os fumigamentos
diminuíram bastante e a sensibilidade da
insulina melhorou 20%. Mas olha só que
coisa interessante, quando você combina
os dois seguindo um protocolo
específico, o resultado é mais potente
ainda do que qualquer um deles isolado.
É como juntar o Pelé e o Garrincha no
mesmo time. Cada um tem a sua
genialidade, mas juntos fazem mágica.
Então o timing é crucial nessa
combinação. Beberina em 30 minutos antes
das refeições principais, alfalipuco
pela manhã em jejum. Nunca os dois
juntos porque eles competem pela
absorção intestinal. É como tentar
passar duas pessoas ao mesmo tempo numa
porta giratória. E aqui vem uma
informação que pode chocar alguns
colegas da medicina convencional.
Adicionar cromo que lá 200 microg e
canela de seilão potencializa o efeito
dos dois. Mas isso são detalhes de
protocolo que a medicina mais
convencional nem sonha em considerar
porque não tem como patentear essa
combinação. Então os resultados
esperados são bem objetivos. Nas
primeiras duas semanas, você já sente
menos fome entre as refeições, menos
aquela lombeira depois do almoço. Em 30
a 60 dias, se você fizer os exames, vai
ver o seu IR melhorado entre 15 a 30%,
glicemia de jejum normalizada. Agora,
uma coisa que me incomoda profundamente
é ver gente usando esses compostos como
se fosse vitamina C. Isso não é
brincadeira, pessoal. Tem que monitorar
com exames específicos. Home, insulina
de jejum, uva gliccêêmica, hemoglobina
glicada, proteína serreativa,
ultrassensível. A visão funcional
trabalha com dados e não com achismo. E
olha que contradição interessante. A
medicina convencional critica esses
compostos por falta de evidência, mas os
estudos estão aí publicados nas melhores
revistas científicas internacionais. A
diferença é que não há interesse
comercial em pesquisar mais a fundo
porque não dá para patentear berberina
ou alfalipuico. O que me deixa mais
frustrado é saber que 97% das pessoas
que poderiam se beneficiar desse
composto estão usando dosagens
inadequadas no time errado, sem
monitoramento adequado. A verdade
conveniente é que a questão não é a
berberina ou alfalipuico. A questão é
que a medicina ortodoxa nunca
consideraria essa combinação
estratégica, porque não é falado em
congressos médicos e não há patente
possível.
Enquanto isso, milhares de pessoas
continuam dependentes de medicamentos
com efeitos colaterais significativos,
quando poderiam estar usando uma
abordagem mais inteligente e com menos
riscos. Se você tem resistência à
insulina e está usando apenas um desses
suplementos, pode estar desperdiçando
tempo e dinheiro. O protocolo que
realmente funciona envolve a combinação
estratégica, timing correto, dosagens
adequadas e monitoramento funcional.
Saia do vídeo agora se você gosta de
ficar no superficial, porque vou te
contar uma verdade inconveniente. O
YouTube e o conselho de medicina me
limitam. Aqui eu preciso simplificar,
censurar dosagens, omitir protocolos
controversos. Na comunidade fechada não
existe filtro. Eu compartilho os exatos
protocolos que eu uso em minha clínica.
Casos de reversão que parecem possíveis
combinações ofel que funcionam,
fornecedores confiáveis. também
interpretação avançada de exames. É
basicamente ter acesso ao meu cérebro
médico sem intermediários. Então você
vai ter acesso a lives semanais
respondendo perguntas PDF com mais de 47
protocolos exclusivos. Grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a medicina
funcional real, sem simplificação para
as massas, clica aqui embaixo, seja
membro. Não é para curiosos, para quem
quer resultados. Yeah.